hier soir au Palais des Sports un jeune
boxeur battu par chaos au premier round
a peut-être vu s'envoler sa dernière
chance de devenir un grand champion
aujourd'hui ça va mieux j'ai fait des
compresses
c'est ma femme qui m'a soignée elle a dû
être déçu votre femme elle a été
surprise elle m'attendait pas si bonheur
oui on peut dire que ça a été rapide le
combat durait combien de temps
exactement
deux minutes 9 secondes
je pose mon œuf je retiens
ça fait une minute 59 ici j'étais sur
moi vous aurez que je sais pas que
j'avais dit du mal de lit je le
connaissais même pas
sauvage je refuse la violence déjà quand
j'étais petit avec mon frère me frappait
ma mère